have a look at your diagram here the
angle of inclination is an angle we're
going to mark on here so if you've got
yet another color I don't know how much
how you going with coming tells you see
this angle right in here right I'm going
to label it right now it's quite warm
I'm going to label that seat up so I'm
going to say feet art ears now how do
you describe this angle like verbally
rather safe is there what features
around that angle to find the angle
what's it between yeah okay for starters
it's like this streamline here by the
way there's another straight line here
which has nothing to do with you what is
it about this straight line is the point
it's alien it's that yet because like if
you put a triangle there you'd say
that's the bottom of at least the base
because it's horizontal right so it's
the x-axis anything else what else into
a better man yeah very good so see this
guy down here and this guy don't need
more RP which they has to be parallel to
each other so in fact if I wanted to
that thing over there missed importantly
this speed up is the same speed up why
is that what's the reason corresponding
angles on parallel lines ready also we
said this is the x-axis right there's
another angle formed between our AV and
x-axis this guy over here not on what I
want I want this one so how would you
distinguish if you were trying to
describe your cell you couldn't draw
anything you just had to use words how
would you say I want this one not that
one send it again okay if you wanted to
calculate this one it would be the
supplement that's the worry is because
Renee degrees minus this angle but what
I'm trying to do is describe to someone
hey can you mark this theta and not this
one what want to achieve you
Syria okay so you can say look I'm
looking on the inside of triangle India
not on the outside and there's a tiny
bit of problem with that even though
this works here
I could turn this line right and going
up I can make go down wait and then
actually the Eagle at what is outside
the triangle not inside so I'm going to
provide to you in here I love your
arrived assuming a little verbal
definition for this image is the angle
between yes sorry it's a theta first
possession of the toggle between
interval a B or PQ or MN or whatever is
that you're comparing together and now
the part that you're looking at right
you guys said x-axis before that was
very helpful but it's not just any part
of the x-axis if there's quite a part
because I can say like this is the
positive side and this is the negative
side I say a B and the positive x-axis
that tells me go this way don't go that
way
and that's what will give you thinner
okay so far so good
now I want to know what the size of that
angle is how can I do it what
information do you know what knowledge
do you have over the last couple of
years that can help you work out an
angle when you've got this kind of
information supplied to any takers
yeah
okay I have a right angle triangle in
here I know that this is 92.9 as well if
I Q this angled in the really really
small in the corner then I could say
this puts this must this is one eighth
so I could work it out the steamy
problem is I don't know what the top
angle is yet anyway I don't know so I
wanted to put that to one side is there
any other information I can use then I
hope you were to either those like the
top one or thinner any suggestions I'll
give you a clue
we drew a big triangle a case of
trigonometry is like literally the name
tree Demetrius measuring triangles okay
so trigonometry can help you with it for
a while can you deep down into your
memory how am I gonna get on the case
sign comment an hour all ratios of links
between science and just have a look
let's look at the VW one in a big
triangle here okay if you're standing
over here on which two sides of the
opportunity I will bring many are two of
them you've got rise which is the
opposite and if you've got one in which
is the adjacent side right so Qatar
which was that that's ten isn't one so
therefore what I can write here
underneath here on the right Tan theta
equals opposite on adjacent in this case
that right that's right over run which
you guys worked out with you before is
five over three so tan theta equals the
gradient
would you inverse okay I'll get to that
in a second so I've written down 10
meter equals 5 over 3 from this right
angle triangle what I don't want and it
up I want feet on right so if you reach
your calculator now we are equals now
you need to press a button on your
calculator there's a 10 button but you
don't want 10 we've already got 10
you've got a undo 10 so above above the
tare button you should see it now just
please make a note even though that's
exactly what it looks like do not ever
read it out like I matter it out as 10
to the power of minus 1 it's not the
greatest notation us people they call
this arc tan to avoid the confusion the
way you read it the way we would read it
and I'd love you to write this down so
you say it properly this is tan inverse
or you can say invest pair those 10
abyss of the order derivative so I want
to get rid of 10 on both sides so I'm
going to turn universe to this that
means your [ __ ] they can handle your
calculator display should look like this
okay um hit equals just be watchful
though um that's all of an answer for me
really no more than your everything to
the poor that's all okay now quick show
a hand
I hope this is not too many of you does
anyone have this so many calculators for
a kid equals and get the different
number anyone like a number around one
okay all right that's good
the only reason why I'm just hesitating
is because especially if you have an
older sibling or a senior student who
stole your calculator if you look really
really hard at the top of the display
can you see there's a bunch of like this
above there one of which says is okay do
you see that like a tiny little square
this dealer
and for degrees degrees our course the
way that we measure angles we've been
doing it two years it's not the only way
them and Nestle if you will find out
about another kind of measure and we've
let your calculator to someone sometimes
they'll change the work is never
supposed to use a different work in
particular you want that you'll learn
about that next year
but if you get a different number at the
end that's how you know something's
wrong
59 degrees does it look like 59 degrees
how they'll be done right I think that's
pretty you go detector yeah okay
now this idea about angled inclination
tan theta is the greatest okay
so underneath this like this is just an
example right eg can you put in a really
nice big box to find the angle of
inclination all you have to say is can
feed our equals the gradient right you
know the gradient of the line you can
find the angles